when I came to this video I'm playing
drunk Todd yeah maybe dangerous drunk
town not sure sober town maybe even more
dangerous no idea okay so I played the
Carol but we linked it very well with
the caro-kann against town but he didn't
play Knight f6 of course jack yeah
everybody and their uncle know that c 3
is the main rules
and kept what to do against this maybe
just get the night out mm yeah okay I'd
really don't want neither form cannot
casts a long a 2 is saying of course f5
this is a weakness
mmm yeah again a rather rather
interesting position from the opening no
idea what's going on really
my idea was where h5 if he plays each
fall and take on a default a kanji three
but this is the idea of a person that
has played too many blitz blitz chess
games in a row it doesn't look too sane
if you if you consider it a bit more in
a bit more sober state okay but damn
maybe this isn't so bad this is quite a
nice bishop okay down all the way back
it's very much possible that I'm in
terrible shape here how do i play this
now but wait maybe yeah I need to do
that moving the Queen again a strange
but this is the only bad side of us
position legs post king king after i'm
going to play 95 rookie one takes takes
bishop b6 and suddenly it's all all
working nicely night f5 maybe you should
play night at 5pm intending 97 this is
the big problem
yeah and after you create shortcuts my
position looks like completely idiotic
mm Wow yeah this happens of you base
your play on some some not to grace
tricks how do I even keep this playable
it's not not easy Luke g8 short castles
57 I can just take vp6 play okay when I
win on a rocky one just am completely
completely terrible
okay let's play completely outrageous
looking move it's probably a crap but
the position is just just terrible
anyway it looks so stupid maybe it
irritates them
I can can play Bishop c4 this our best
option for
I do I could actually take here then
okay let's uh
I take here still be a bishop seafoam
okay
now this is hanging with check check
with doesn't that doesn't really help I
mean I assured by five was coming anyway
okay here i can i can take see for at
least a buddy can take on e5 and then
bishop at five yeah it's just a disaster
this game yeah it is the drunk one not
me but it really looked like you i had a
few few beers tomb too many push up at
five yeah and black resigned what a
disaster yes was probably probably just
bad yeah this move find em gap it's just
another five is just just picking this
this apart no no move now it's just
terrible
yeah it probably started with Bishop b6
should just continue here with
developing and then it's a problem a
relatively normal game with with
actually castling not King d8 and stuff
yeah i played this really far to
creatively to put it in a positive way
also badly thanks for watching